buenas tardes soy camino garcía
directora del instituto de ciencia y
tecnología de los alimentos de la
universidad de león cuya fachada no se
observa muy bien en el norte vemos en la
en la zona derecha de la
de la pantalla bien este instituto lleva
trabajando para el sector alimentario
tanto leonés como del entorno y para las
entidades públicas desde 1998 y es muy
importante porque debemos de
interiorizar que el sector
agroalimentario es un sector estratégico
en la provincia que desde el punto de
vista económico en la provincia de león'
bueno para intentar enmarcar mi charla
e ir avanzando en aspectos que tampoco
quiero solapar me mucho con mis colegas
doctor mauricio y doctor martín lo
primero que tenemos porque el consumidor
normalmente lo equivoca lo hace es
sinónimo es diferenciar las actuaciones
del campo de la alimentación y la
nutrición son muy dependientes pero no
son iguales la alimentación son los
actos que realizamos para aportar los
alimentos actos por lo tanto son
voluntarios conscientes y educables esto
es muy importante que lo fijemos la
nutrición en cambio son procesos
fisiológicos nosotros a través de esos
componentes que llamamos nutrientes que
contienen los alimentos
una vez digeridos absorbidos y
metabolizados los utilizamos como fuente
de energía materia plástica y reparadora
entonces no tienes que quedar muy claro
que la nutrición son procesos
fisiológicos
no está al alcance de nuestra voluntad
es inconsciente es involuntario por
tanto no podemos nunca educar un proceso
fisiológico
si las decisiones que realizamos en el
campo de la alimentación son correctas
por ende queremos es decir si estamos
bien alimentados por ende estaremos bien
nutridos otra cosa que normalmente el
consumidor no se da cuenta es que la
nutrición es una ciencia relativamente
moderna se han tenido que desarrollar
otras muchas y su avance es muy lento
porque los estudios experimentales en
seres humanos tienen la limitación de
que no puedes comprometer es decir la
nutrición humana avanza muy lentamente
porque no podemos comprometer ni la
salud ni la vida del individuo va mucho
más avanzada la nutrición animal
además en este nuevo siglo vamos a
asistir a grandes descubrimientos con el
desarrollo de las llamadas ciencias
cómicas que mi colega anterior doctor
mauri y ha desarrollado en algunos
apartados no sólo eso sino vamos a
profundizar en el papel que tiene la
microbiota intestinal en la
funcionalidad y en la integridad
funcional de nuestro organismo esa
llamada antiguamente flora intestinal
tiene un papel muy importante porque
esos microorganismos y los metabolitos
que generan a través de la utilización
que hacen de los nutrientes que
ingerimos en la dieta la utilización que
hacen de los mismos en el intestino que
es como una verdadera fábrica
de producir metabolitos pues esos esos
metabolitos mandan señales neurales y
endocrinas no sólo al intestino mismo
sino a distintos órganos e incluso
tejidos distantes un ejemplo es el
tejido nervioso el cerebro
la incidencia que tiene esta microbiota
en la funcionalidad por ejemplo del
comportamiento
y del estado de ánimo es decir por
ponernos un ejemplo un ejemplo no una
realidad que veremos en un futuro
próximo a lo mejor una dieta
desequilibrada nos va a determinar una
desvío sis microbiana que nos va a
afectar por ejemplo el tener mayor
predisposición para una depresión
además
asistimos también en estos años los
últimos años a una gran cantidad de
información que crece exponencialmente
sobre los temas de alimentación y
nutrición no tenemos no tenemos tiempo
para integrar esa información para
analizarla y generar a veces pues los
mensajes que debe emanar de la
literatura científica normalmente el
consumidor se queja y a veces tiene
razón de que los mensajes son muy
contradictorios el por una parte puede
ser debido a que en ese tema en concreto
no hay todavía un consenso en la
comunidad científica y por otra parte
porque los mensajes los mitos se
consolidan en una los mitos que se
consolidan en una ciencia obsoleta
penetra mucho en la población es difícil
erradicar esos mitos otro aspecto que no
voy a tratar más que de pasada pero que
es muy importante y nos ayuda a veces a
entender el tema alimentario
en un segundo plano aquí se es un mundo
de negocio donde se mueven miles de
millones de euros de euros de dólares
etcétera etcétera no olvidemos que
diariamente se producen y se venden
millones de miles de toneladas de
alimentos eso hace que a veces haya
verdaderas luchas por cuotas de mercado
que lleve que lleven a difundir mensajes
pseudo engañosos sobre un determinado
alimento los últimos años el ataque que
hay a la leche de vaca es una opinión
personal mía
otro aspecto que tenemos que analizar
porque el acto alimentario hemos dicho
que es el de proveernos de alimentos que
es voluntario claro que nos influye qué
factores nos influyen tradicionalmente
los factores que nos influyen en la
literatura pues están los
socioculturales religiosos
derivados sobre todo de las producciones
las producciones alimentarias que según
la climatología y la orografía se dieran
en los determinados territorios y
comíamos lo que se producía en la zona
dicho vulgarmente
sin embargo hoy en día estamos en una
sociedad post-industrial que cada vez
hay un porcentaje mayor de personas
ese porcentaje de personas de mayor edad
crece incesantemente además hay un
número cada vez más importante de
adultos que se afanan en el cultivo de
su propia inmadurez
aunque suene fuerte le piden cada vez
más a la vida y entienden cada vez menos
el mundo que les rodea de manera que
está en crisis el cultivo del
pensamiento del razonamiento del por
ejemplo del entendimiento y vamos
sustituyéndolo por la cultura de lo
inmediato y de lo digamos caprichoso
satisfacción instantánea quiero esto lo
quiero ya es muy común entonces si esos
si estamos en esta sociedad
infantilizada y es a nivel global es una
cuestión simplemente de nuestro país lo
normal es que los factores que nos
induzcan en el acto alimentario sean los
facto
o sea la alimentación es un placer si
haces una encuesta a usted porque come
esto porque me gusta claro lo normal lo
evaluamos mediante los sentidos a través
del color olor sabor textura de los
alimentos y cómo es lo que nos gusta
sin embargo y esto hay que tener en
cuenta los últimos años si está
observando y ya no digo nada en estos
dos últimos años que cada vez comemos
más emocionalmente frente a situaciones
de estrés ansiedades y sobre todo por la
incertidumbre que nos rodea y esto es un
tema que hay que tener en cuenta
además otros factores que nos van a
condicionar al acto alimentario son la
información que recibimos por publicidad
medios redes sociales que hoy en día nos
rodean
además darnos cuenta que el mensaje
cualquiera cualquiera sea profesional o
no
experto o no cualquiera pública
recomendaciones opiniones sobre el tema
alimentario y lo normal que no debería
ser es que el usuario todo lo ponga al
mismo nivel lo reciben y lo programa al
mismo nivel
tenemos un ejemplo en este por poner
ejemplos de este último año una
instagram de española que se hizo famosa
anunciando el beber agua deshidrata
semejante burrada científica pero tuvo
muchos likes ella estaba feliz porque
subió a la ranking de las instalarán y
así estamos
otro factor que nos condiciona y esto se
ha visto ya desde la crisis del 200 del
2008 es el factor precio desde luego
muchas personas estos hacen estudios de
mercado compra por ofertas y promociones
es humano no hay nada en los alimentos
caros especiales o sea se puede llevar
una dieta muy sana siendo una dieta
barata teniendo baratos que sí que hay
que tener unos recursos basándose en la
pero si no tiene está no tiene tampoco
buena la cesta la compración que hoy
vamos a hablar de la fiesta la compra
básica pues en esos alimentos el
problema es que por lo menos en los
últimos meses yo lo veo un problema
están aumentando los precios de grupos
de alimentos que son básicos en nuestra
dieta como es el caso de las frutas y
verduras frescas y esto habría que
hacérselo mirar
por ejemplo rebajando oliva
otra cosa que demanda al consumidor es
que no tiene tiempo en esta sociedad el
tiempo es un bien escaso tengo que
chatear tengo que ligar por tim detengo
las horas no me dan de sí consecuencia
no tengo tiempo para cocinar
qué tengo que hacer
pues
asumir una cosa que si no se cocina un
mínimo no se puede llevar una dieta sana
salvo que tengas es un gran presupuesto
económico valió en casa que te cociné
queso ya no se da
la industria alimentaria detecta todo
esto porque ellos hay que tener en
cuenta siempre hablamos mal pero en
realidad su función es vender si no
cierran detecta que nos gusta a lo
ridículo gustoso lo barato y lo cómodo
lo que un modelo fácil de utilizar y que
hace pues diseña alimentos con este fin
alimentos muy gustosos muy palatables
adictivos como ha dicho el doctor mauri
a base de añadir azúcar añadir grasa
añadir perdón grasa barata añadir sal
añadía aditivos potenciadores de sabor
del color etcétera entonces tenemos una
oferta de alimentos
palatables o ricos nadie va a decir que
está malo porque para eso lo diseñan
rico barato fácil de utilizar envuelto
en un gran marketing y quien se puede
resistir entes mientras que procesados
tradicionales como el ramo de esta lata
de conserva de pescado pues nadie le
hace el marketing no son tendencia
que tenemos que apostar pues por la
comida real aspectos que ya han recogido
otros conferenciantes la comida real
sabores naturales ya se nos han olvidado
a veces los sabores naturales de algún
alimento porque nunca los hemos tomado
sin echarle azúcar o sin echarles algo
sabores naturales si queremos que sea
barato aprovechar los alimentos de
estación porque al ver mayor oferta va a
ser más barato y luego el 'kilómetro
cero'
estamos tan concienciados pues hay que
buscar y ver alimentos de proximidad
porque va a ser muy importante para el
mantenimiento de la población rural
fijaros en el entorno en la que estamos
en una de las provincias más envejecidas
de europa
además hay que organizar nuestro tiempo
saber que hay que planificar lo que
comemos hay que planificar la compra hay
que planificar cómo se elabora la
alimentación hay que cocinar como dije
antes si no se cocina no se puede llevar
una dieta sana hay que hacer
aprovechamiento de sobras hay que evitar
el desperdicio alimentario hay que
cocinar lo que se hizo toda la vida es
decir por los fines de semana si no
tengo tiempo preparo ya una serie de
reacciones que luego solo re caliento
que hoy en día tiene un término porque
todo hoy en día tiene términos el batch
cooking hay verdaderos expertos en
backup y la otra cosa yo como profesora
me llega al alma porque a veces se nos
olvida la educación hay que educar para
luchar contra toda esta desinformación
que nos rodea y hay que educar en
contenidos que tienen que ver con la
alimentación nutrición y seguridad
alimentaria y con la cultura de la
alimentación de astronomía y por qué y
además quiero
el sector más sensible y mejor se
cimentan hábitos alimentarios y esto
está estudiado muy bien por el doctor
valentín fuster que es una referencia en
nuestro país es la edad de 3 a 6 años
que nos parece imposible esa edad se
cimentan los hábitos alimentarios y si
queremos tener consumidores críticos que
puedan analizar toda esta información
que les llega en catarata debemos de
introducir estos contenidos en el
sistema de educación desde la infancia
y además hay que tener en cuenta que hay
que cambiar el paradigma porque si no
como ha dicho el doctor mattis vamos a
abocados a una sociedad enferma y
sostenible
lo barato y cómodo en la alimentación a
largo plazo sale caro nuestra salud ya
hemos dicho las patologías relacionadas
por ello y el medio ambiente
en realidad la evidencia científica se
sustenta en un saber popular es que da
pena
tanto este tanto estudiar ya al final
llegamos a lo que dice la abuela en el
pueblo en las gallinas que entra por las
que salen el equilibrio entre lo que
quiero y lo que gasto no hay más
a día de hoy otra cosa es que con los
avances que se produzcan con estas
nuevas tecnologías podamos pues primero
el individuación ser único podamos hacer
más precisiones para día de hoy esto de
una situación de equilibrio entre lo que
hicieron lo que gasto hay dos frases que
a mí me gusta mucho el doctor fuster
come más vegetales y animal
casi el 75% de nuestra dieta debe ser
vegetal y ahí están incorporados los
cereales las legumbres frutas verduras
frutos secos etcétera etcétera otro 25
por ciento deberían ser para proteínas
de alto valor biológico carne pescado
huevos legumbres
y se más animal que vegetal los animales
se mueven somos animales somos mamíferos
las plantas no y cuando decimos movernos
y el doctor mauricio nos vamos a dar un
paseíto si el ejercicio aeróbico está
muy bien pero hay más que el ejercicio
aeróbico al músculo hay que darle hay
que machacar lo hay que darle traía hay
que ejercitar la fuerza porque está
totalmente demostrado que el músculo es
un órgano endocrino que produce cuando y
cuando se hace ejercicio se producen
unas proteínas que se denominan miosina
somió finas que tienen unas importantes
funciones no sólo sobre el propio
músculo sino sobre otros órganos y
sistemas las vecinas ya está demostrado
que participan en la regulación del peso
corporal
el modulación de la inflamación de bajo
grado en la sensibilidad a la insulina
tan importante en diabetes tipo 2 en la
supresión del crecimiento tumoral e
incluso en la mejora
de la función cognitiva es decir vamos a
menos pastillas menos ansiolíticos y más
sentadillas la cosa no es tan difícil al
final es una cultura que claro en esta
sociedad infantil hablar del esfuerzo y
el día que pesada esta es una estrella
desde el otro milenio
hay que responsabilizarse de la salud
somos una especie muy vulnerable ha
quedado patente como dice el doctor
lópez otín es un milagro que estemos
vivos todavía porque vivir es un riesgo
la principal apuesta que podemos hacer
por nuestra salud a medio y largo plazo
es el cuidado de la dieta teniendo en
cuenta que da lo mismo la edad da lo
mismo que tengas 20 40 60 80 años si
mejora es tu dieta mejorar la salud
cuando dices tu dieta no solo es lo que
como es el concepto hipocrático lo que
como mi estilo de vida mi actividad
física no drogarme no fumar no beber
intentar tener un equilibrio emocional
cosa que va a cosas complicadas pero es
así lo que se llama un término que ahora
se está gestando el autocuidado porque
nosotros debemos de responsabilizarnos
de nuestra salud si queremos
en épocas ya más avanzadas de nuestra
vida no ser personas dependientes que es
una gran tristeza para el individuo y
una gran carga para la familia y para el
sistema sanitario
nada más muchas gracias
[Aplausos]